foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing notorious werewolf fenrir
greybag digging into his past and
uncovering some things that you may have
never known believe it or not once upon
a time fenrir greybag was just a regular
wizard he didn't have sharp teeth long
yellow nails whiskers or hair sprouting
from every part of his body he also
didn't transform into a horrible
dangerous magical creature when a full
moon filled the sky there is speculation
out there pertaining to whether or not
greybach was ever a wizard at all but as
it happens Rowling has confirmed that
only Wizards are able to transform into
werewolves after being bitten by one and
that Muggles simply die this if it
wasn't clear already confirms the fact
that greybag was indeed a wizard in fact
though information on him is sparse the
available evidence would suggest that
Grayback was perhaps even once a student
at Hogwarts just like Harry Ron and
Hermione this fact would explain his
magical skills his connections within
the Death Eaters and his hatred of
normal wizards but on one fateful day
presumably after his visiting education
had finished wizard Grayback who likely
was already of dubious morality had an
encounter with a werewolf where he was
bitten at this moment fenrir was
infected with lycanthropy by the unnamed
werewolf a magical Affliction that
transforms witches and wizards into
werewolves one who was infected with
lycanthropy is henceforth known as a
lycanthrope there are two ways to become
a lycanthrope but regardless of how it
is contracted it is still considered to
be a curse for which there is no cure
that will completely alter the victim's
existence the first and most common way
to contract lycanto therapy is through
being bitten by a werewolf though in
some circumstances the bite can well
kill you you must also be bitten by a
werewolf in their wolfish form at the
time of the full moon ensuring the
werewolf's saliva mingles with the
victim's blood and the second way is via
the lycacomia curse which apparently
requires no werewolves at all
though inheriting lycanthropy doesn't
kill you and to some the prospect of
becoming a werewolf may be exciting I
can assure you that it is no easy
existence the stigma in a Wizarding
World surrounding werewolves is immense
and from the moment you contract this
curse it's unlikely that you will ever
be treated the same many werewolves live
very solitary lives as allowing people
to become closer to you only puts their
lives in danger once infected with
lycanthropy the victim will turn from a
man into a werewolf every month during
the full moon the transformation itself
has been described as exceedingly
painful and once transformed the wizard
in question will completely lose their
sense of right and wrong from the point
of transformation they are completely
unaware of their actions for these
reasons the ministry of magic developed
the werewolf code of conduct in 1637 a
werewolf code of conduct was developed
in in 1637 which werewolves were
supposed to sign promising not to attack
anyone but to lock themselves up
securely every month unsurprisingly
nobody signed the code as nobody was
prepared to walk into the ministry and
admit to being a werewolf a problem from
which the later werewolf registry also
suffered for years this werewolf
registry on which every werewolf was
supposed to enter their name in personal
details has remained incomplete and
unreliable because so many of the newly
bitten sought to conceal their condition
and escaped the inevitable shame and
Exile the werewolf code of conduct might
have had good intentions but it also
required a werewolf to out their status
and face the consequences from the
moment they registered their name they
would face an immediate loss of both
rights and Status werewolves have been
chanted between the Beast and being
divisions of the department for the
regulation and control of magical
creatures for years because nobody could
make up their minds whether a werewolf
should be classified as a human or
beastial unsurprisingly when fenrir
greyback was bitten he had no intentions
of registering his werewolf status with
the ministry venrir loathed transforming
into a werewolf each month and for a
long time felt as though he was living a
cursed existence But as time went on
venra's perspective on his condition
began to shift one day realizing that
his condition was a gift and not a curse
at all the lack of understanding and
empathy from the outside world toward
his condition and drove him to anger
anger which he used his fuel to get back
at the world that had rejected him
instead of accepting a life as an
outcast he embraced his condition and
made it his goal to create enough
werewolves to dominate The Wizarding
World his goal was simple in fact as
many people as possible venra grebach is
perhaps the most Savage werewolf alive
today he regards it as his mission in
life to bite and to contaminate as many
people as possible he wants to create
enough werewolves to overcome the
Wizards Voldemort has promised him prey
in return for his Services greyback
specializes in children bite them young
he says and raise them away from their
parents raise them to hate normal
Wizards it's also worth noting that as
far as werewolves go greyback was
particularly Savage While most
werewolves only unintentionally bit
people during their transform stage
greyback went out of his way to bite
people even in his human form completely
cognizant of his behavior and brutality
his sheer hatred for Humanity meant that
no one man woman or child was safe in
fact greyback had a penchant for biting
children because Grayback skirted so
closely on the border of man and
werewolf for so many years he eventually
began to resemble a werewolf even while
in his human form greyback's attitude
and Devotion to the werewolf cause
eventually prompted him to become a
leader in the werewolf Community with
him and his pack of werewolves wrecking
all sorts of Havoc across Britain during
the 1960s but despite leading a
revolution of his own fenra greybach was
at this stage recruited by the Death
Eaters who were seeking all manners of
dark creatures to help them overthrow
the ministry greback didn't join them
because he believed in their cause but
instead because it gave him greater
access to potential victims as well as
an additional channel of attack against
the ministry it's also worth mentioning
that fenrir was never given true Death
Eater status for the very fact that he
was a lycanthrope the stigma in The
Wizarding Community toward werewolves
was not exclusive to the good guys and
despite loathing werewolves Voldemort
recognized that fenrir was a powerful
weapon Voldemort knew that he would be
able to take advantage defenry's
notoriety to help control The Wizarding
population and escalate his own rise to
power it didn't matter to Voldemort that
he was a werewolf not really he held
some stigma towards him which is why he
would have never made him a Death Eater
but Voldemort's real enemies were
muckleborns half-bloods Muggles and
blood traitors fenrir wasn't the only
follower of Voldemort that wasn't a pure
blood wizard either he enlisted Giants
dementos and all other manners of dark
creatures to help bring down the
ministry and the good guys Voldemort was
manipulative and he basically did
whatever it took to get to power the
fastest if people were willing to work
for him under the guise that they were
somehow important he would certainly let
that happen it was a win-win for him
Voldemort began to use fenra's notoriety
to instill fear into the hearts of his
enemies threatening to send the
horrifying webwolf after their children
who he had a propensity killing in the
year 1965 likely before Voldemort had
enlisted his Services greyback was
brought in for questioning by the
ministry of magic to discuss an attack
on two muggle children that have
resulted in their deaths while being
questioned by a room full of ministry
officials greyback pleaded ignorance
claiming to be a Muckle [ __ ] who was
amazed to have found himself in a room
full of wizards talking about dead
children his filthy clothing and lack of
wand was sufficient evidence enough for
most to believe him his Saving Grace
being the inadequacy and Ill maintenance
of the werewolf registry which did not
feature his name however there was one
Committee Member Lyle Lupine who noticed
physical peculiarities on greybag
consistent with the werewolf this
prompted him to ask the committee that
greybach be kept in detention until the
next full moon which was just one day
away the other committee members
mutually agreed that this cautionary
measure was unnecessary and at this
stage greyback began taunting Lupine in
his anger Lupine began describing
werewolves as soulless evil and
deserving of nothing but death
something that greybach would never
forget following lupine's Outburst He
was ordered out of the room and the
Grayback was subsequently released
however before the wizard who escorted
him out of the inquiry was able to cast
a memory charm on Grayback erasing the
Muckle tramps memory greybak overpowered
him and fled along with three other
werewolves from this day greyback began
plotting his revenge of Lyle Lupine the
wizard who was so outspoken about him
deserving nothing but death one fateful
night greyback forced his way through
the window into the Lupine Family Home
and attacked Lyle's son Remus he wasn't
even five years old yet
grayback's attack of Lyle's son was
consistent with his previous Behavior
involving the targeting of children Lyle
awoke to a kerfuffle in his family home
and headed straight for his son's room
where he had to cast powerful spells in
order to get rid of greybank but
unfortunately for the family it was too
late before Lyle intervened greyback had
succeeded in infecting Lyle's son Remus
with lycanthropy this of course meant
that Lyle's own son had become a
werewolf it was never greyback's
intention to kill Remus he knew exactly
what he was doing when he infected him
his actions resulted in the ultimate
revenge against the man who so openly
expressed that all werewolves were
deserving of nothing but death
remus's parents took him to various
healers in order to cure him of his
condition but unfortunately until the
discovery of the wolf Spain potion there
was nothing that could even remotely
suppress the curse I was a very small
boy when I received the bite my parents
tried everything but in those days there
was no cure the potion that Professor
Snape has been making for me is a very
recent discovery it makes me safe you
see as long as I take it in the week
preceding the full moon I keep my mind
when I transform I'm able to curl up in
my office a harmless wolf and wait for
the moon to whine again before the
wolfspan potion was discovered however I
became a fully fledged monster once a
month it seemed impossible that I would
be able to come to Hogwarts other
parents weren't likely to want their
children exposed to me remus's infection
with lycanthropy meant that he too would
live a cursed existence a solitary life
full of judgment it was only thanks to
Albus dumb door who arranged special
accommodations for Remus that he was
able to attend Hogwarts content with
exacting his revenge upon Lyle greyback
continued with his savagery for quite
some time eventually the ministry caught
on and finally began to acknowledge that
greybag was indeed a werewolf and that
he was exceedingly dangerous in response
to the activities of greybach and his
pack of werewolves the ministry failed
The Wizarding population once again by
merely putting up a wanted poster
greybach was never caught during the
first Wizarding War which meant that for
many many years him and his pack of
werewolves terrorized The Wizarding
population however after Voldemort's
defeat in 1981 greyback like many others
presumed that Voldemort was dead and
never made any attempts to find him no
longer protected by the safety net of
Voldemort and his cause greybak and his
werewolves retreated into the Shadows at
least for a little while
when Voldemort finally returned in 1995
greybach rejoined his cause and resumed
his duties performing dirty work for the
dark lord graback's notoriety was a
particularly valuable asset for
Voldemort as the prospect of facing a
terrifying cannibalistic werewolf would
strike fear into the hearts of even the
most Fearless witches and wizards but it
wasn't just his notoriety that served a
purpose greybach was personally involved
in many conflicts over the course of the
second Wizarding War shortly after the
battle of the Department of mysteries
greyback raided Diagon Alley and
kidnapped wandmaker Garrick olivander it
was during this time that he also along
with some other Death Eaters waged an
attack on the mughals by destroying the
Millennium bridge in London following
that he made a visit to Borger and Berks
along with Draco Malfoy where they
threatened Mr Borgen for his compliance
in the scheme to transport Death Eaters
into Hogwarts via the vanishing cabinets
following that grow back terrorized the
Montgomery family by attacking and
subsequently killing her five-year-old
son on the orders of the Death Eaters by
this point in time greyback had formed
the new habit of eating his victims
after killing them all while remaining
in his human form this fact is a
testament to Grayback savagery as most
werewolves had no desire to consume
human flesh outside of their wolf form
on June 30th 1997 Grayback joined the
Death Eaters in their invasion of
Hogwarts eventually finding their way to
the astronomy Tower where Alba's
Dumbledore was located and later killed
that you fenrir are stumbledore that's
right rasp the other pleased to see me
Dumbledore no I cannot say that I am
fenrik reback grinned showing pointed
teeth blood trickled down his chin and
he licked his lips slowly obscenely
following Dumbledore's death at the
hands of Severus name the battle of the
astronomy Tower ensued a battle where
greyback was able to attack and Scar the
face of Bill Weasley fortunately for
Bill however Grayback was not in his
wolf form at the time of the attack
which meant that he was not infected
with any sort of lycanthropy after
attacking Bill greyback set his sights
on Harry who countered with the full
body bind curse paralyzing him after the
battle greyback was captured along with
some of his fellow Death Eaters and
subsequently sent to Azkaban however his
imprisonment didn't last long as he
escaped just one month later following
this and the subsequent fall of the
ministry of magic greyback joined the
snatchers an organization of bounty
hunters formed by Lord Voldemort where
he assumed a position of leadership
along with the other snatchers greyback
scoured the countryside looking for
fugitive mugglebones blood traitors and
others who opposed Lord Voldemort cause
while operating as a snatcher grayback's
first successful Bounty was Finding and
capturing Dirk Creswell TED Talks Dean
Thomas and Goblin's grip hook and
gornuck Dean and grip hook were
captioned and imprisoned while Dirk Ted
and gornag were murdered following this
however Grayback and his gang would find
a much more valuable group of fugitives
a group comprised of none other than Ron
Weasley Hermione Granger and Harry
Potter suspecting that these three were
in fact the fabled trio but not being
able to confirm it greybach and the
snatchers brought Harry and gang to
Malfoy Manor with the expectation that
Lucius Narcissa Bellatrix or Draco would
be able to identify Harry and reward
them just before being captured by the
snatchers Hermione successfully hit
Harry with a stinging Jinx deforming his
face this made Harry nearly
unrecognizable when Bellatrix Lestrange
bought a godric gryffindor's sword among
the captives possessions she went to
Proclaim her sword which she believed to
be in her vaulted gring Gods however
this was much to these snatchers dismay
the snatchers who believed that this
item now belonged to them protested her
taking it which resulted in Bellatrix
defeating all four of them it's unclear
what exactly happened next but it's safe
to assume that greyback was punished by
Voldemort along with Bellatrix the
malfoys for letting Harry and gang
escape the next major event where we see
Grayback is the Battle of Hogwarts where
he relished in all of the Bloodshed as
far as we know the only suspected
fatality as a result of greybag was
Hogwarts student lavender Brown who he
Savaged before being repelled by
Hermione Granger and finished off by
Sybil trolloni two bodies fell from the
balcony overhead as they reached the
ground a gray blur that Harry took for
an animal sped four-legged across the
hall to sink its teeth into one of the
Fallen no shrieked Hermione and with a
deafening Blast from her wand fenrik
graback was thrown backward from the
feebly struggling body of lavender Brown
he hit the marble banisters and
struggled to return to his feet then
with a bright white Flash and a crack a
crystal ball fell on top of his head and
he crumpled to the ground and did not
move it's a little hard to interpret
what exactly happened to fenrir after
this as his fate could be interpreted
differently from book to film in the
film fenrir is blasted by Hermione's
stunning spell and sent flying off into
the Ravine below presumably to his death
however this scene from the film
actually contradicts the book as in the
book greyback shows up again later in
the battle Hermione did hit him with a
blasting curse but it never killed him
and probably didn't send him flying as
far as is shown in the film though the
above passage seemed to depict the end
of greybag chapter 36 reveals that this
is in fact not the case as ultimately
Ron and Neville were responsible for
taking down the notorious werewolf Harry
saw Ron and Neville bringing down fenra
greybank and before stunning Rookwood
Arthur and Percy flooring thickness and
Lucius and Narcissa Malfoy running
through the crowd not even attempting to
fight screaming for their son and this
is a loss we hear of him but what does
brought down really mean did Ron and
Neville fire a killing curse what did
they do to him in my opinion Ron and
Neville would not have killed him simply
stunned him which leaves his fate fairly
open-ended I've got two theories for
what happened to him the first
possibility is that Grayback was simply
picked up off of the ground still
stunned after the battle put to trial
and sent into Azkaban and it would be in
Azkaban that greybach would spend the
remainder of his ears but something
about this just doesn't seem right to me
I can't explain why but I think the
Grayback escaped he's an elusive
werewolf that lurked in the shadows for
most of his life furthermore being a
werewolf he was particularly resilient
and would have been able to take much
more of a beating than say a normal
wizard after the battle of Hogwarts I
think he slipped away and regrouped with
other werewolves taking a step back and
biding their time before ultimately
plotting to attack The Wizarding World
once again and that pretty much
concludes the life story of fenrik
rayback for now what do you guys think
did I miss anything what surprised you
about fenrir's history be sure to leave
a comment down below also if you enjoy
the content please be sure to like the
video and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live